Okay.
We're coming to the end of this
short course.
Here, I want to show you the SPECS
acronym one more time and
the five ideas it helps us remember.
It may be helpful to write these
down on a piece of paper and
stick it someplace close
to your computer, so
you can remind yourself of these when
you are actually doing code reviews.
Now before we end,
I want to share with you a few
reviews that we think are excellent.
These reviews incorporate all of the
five ideas from the acronym SPECS that
we've been talking about in this course
and will give you a benchmark for
the kind of quality that we're
looking for in our reviews.
So skip ahead to read some of these
reviews that we consider to be stellar.